veamos una reacción de adición de un día
no conjugado entonces pues aquí tenemos
nuestro de lleno conjugado y le voy a
agregar un ácido clorhídrico voy a
numerar mi bien o conjugado no pensando
en la nomenclatura solo enumerando lo
para identificar cada posición de cada
carbono del bien o sabemos que el primer
paso del mecanismo es que los electrones
pili y uno de estos enlaces pgje va a
funcionar como una base y llevarse un
protón entonces voy a decir que estos
electrones de este enlace doble este
enlace doble entre el carbono 1 y el
carbono 2 van a funcionar como una base
y se van a llevar un protón del ácido
clorhídrico así es que este par de
electrones se va a enlazar con este
protón y entonces estos electrones de
este enlace se van a ir con el cloro así
es que ahora dibujemos por aquí el
resultado de esta reacción ha sido base
pero como no le salen bien los hexágonos
voy a pegarlo simplemente aunque lo voy
a pegar por aquí
y entonces tengo dos opciones agregar el
protón en el carbono 2 o agregar el
protón en el carbono 1 y voy a escoger
el carbono 1 porque eso haría que el
carbono 2 por el carbó catión aunque
este carbono ahora tiene una carga
positiva y es un kart vocaciòn al ico
porque está enlazado con este carbono de
aquí que es un carbono y brie visado sp2
y además es un carbono terciario
entonces es un kart vocación muy estable
en este paso acabamos de formar un
cloruro
duro
con su carga formal negativa y esa carga
formal negativa va a funcionar como un
núcleo filo y el núcleo filo va a atacar
al electro filo carga supuesta se atraen
y entonces se va a formar un enlace y
vamos a obtener el siguiente producto y
entonces voy a volver a pegar un
hexágono por aquí agregamos un protón en
el carbono 1 y un cloro o sea un
halógeno en el carbono 2 carbono 1 de
carbono 2 entonces el producto adulto
que tenemos aquí es el aductor 12 que
aquí tenemos nuestro doble enlace
y aquí tenemos nuestro cloro y el protón
entonces pongamos el nombre de acuerdo
al sistema upac y para nombrarlo de
acuerdo al sistema iupac lo que tenemos
que hacer es numerar estos carbonos de
tal forma que el enlace doble esté en la
posición más baja entonces este carbono
es el 1 este carbono es el 2 y este
carbono es el número 3 así es que
tenemos un cloro en el carbono 3 y un
grupo metilo en el carbono 3 entonces
tenemos 3 cloro
3 metil me el ciclo escena
i
este es un posible producto pero podemos
regresar aquí a nuestro carbón al ico y
dibujar su otra estructura de resonancia
entonces voy a poner los paréntesis las
flechas y pegar aquí otro hexágono ok
ahora tenemos aquí un enlace doble y
podemos tomar este enlace doble y
pasarlo por aquí y pasarlo por aquí y de
todas formas seguimos teniendo aquí este
grupo metilo y seguimos teniendo el
protón agregado en este carbono pero
ahora como a este carbono le quitamos un
enlace este carbono es el carbó catión
con carga positiva y además sigue siendo
un kart vocación al ico y el cloruro
sigue pudiendo atacar a éste carbó
catión en el carbono que está en la
posición 4 porque carga supuesto se
atrae y entonces el producto que
obtenemos tenemos por aquí un hexágono
el protón lo seguimos agregando en el
carbono número 1 pero ahora el halógeno
lo agregamos en el carbono número 4
entonces es un adulto 14 y de producto
obtenemos este ciclo externo que ahora
tiene el doble enlace aquí sigue
teniendo un grupo metilo aquí y ahora
tiene un cloro por aquí ahora si
queremos ponerles un nombre en el
sistema upac tenemos que empezar a
enumerar por aquí y queremos que este
sea el carbono 1 2 y 3 para ponerle el
menor número a los sustituye entes
entonces su nombre iupac es tiene un
cloro en el carbono 3
cloro cloro un grupo metilo en el
carbono 11 metil
metí y es un ciclo 'escena ciclo
así es que como podemos ver son
productos distintos y esto es lo que
obtuvimos utilizando el enlace doble
entre el carbono 1 y el carbono 2 como
el ácido sin embargo también pudimos
haber utilizado el enlace doble entre el
carbono 3 y el carbono 4 ok este enlace
doble y justo ahora lo que vamos a hacer
es ver qué pasaría si hubiéramos
utilizado este enlace doble como el
ácido entonces necesitamos más espacio y
entonces vamos a dibujar el día no
original por aquí tiene un enlace doble
por aquí otro enlace doble por aquí y un
grupo metilo por aquí pero ahora el
enlace doble que vamos a usar como una
base es este de aquí entonces podemos
dibujar al ácido clorhídrico por aquí
y otra vez voy a numerar mis carbonos
pero
sin preocuparme por la nomenclatura
iupac ok sólo los voy a enumerar para
poder identificar mejor dónde están
entonces voy a decir que este es el
carbono 12
y 4 sólo para poder seguir en donde
están no para utilizarlos en la
nomenclatura entonces cuando pienso en
el primer paso de este mecanismo y
pienso que es una reacción ácido base
donde mis electrones van a quedarse con
un protón y entonces estos electrones de
aquí se van a quedar con el cloro
tenemos que pegar otra vez un ciclo
hexano que sigue teniendo un doble
enlace por aquí un grupo metilo y este
doble enlace se va a quedar con un
protón pero tenemos que pensar en cuál
de los dos carbonos se va a quedar el
protón y bueno el protón se va a quedar
en este carbono porque sería que éste
fuera el carb ocasión
este es un cargo catión secundario pero
además es un kart vocación al lille y
ccoo porque está enlazado con este
carbono y british a 2 sp2 entonces es
una provocación bastante estable y otra
vez en este mecanismo el unión cloruro
con su carga negativa va a funcionar con
un núcleo filo así es que este a nyon
cloruro con su carga negativa va a ser
un ataque núcleo físico a este carbono
con carga positiva y así ya obtenemos el
producto que déjame dibujo la estructura
de punto tenemos un ciclo hexano por
aquí seguimos teniendo un doble enlace
por aquí un grupo metilo por aquí un
protón por aquí y ahora tenemos además
un cloro por aquí entonces tenemos un 12
abductor y si estamos pensando en estos
números que puso por aquí agregamos un
protón en la posición número uno y luego
agregamos un cloro en la posición número
así es que tenemos una víctor 12
y ahora vamos a ponerles un nombre iupac
y empezamos a enumerar a partir del
enlace doble y de tal forma que el
sustituye ente tenga el menor número
posible entonces este es el carbono 12
siguiendo el doble enlace 3 4 5 y 6 si
es que tenemos un cloro en el carbono 6
entonces esto es 6 cloro un metilo en el
carbono 11 metil etil ciclo externo
ciclo
seno y ahora podemos regresar al kart
vocación al ico y ver la estructura de
resonancia de esta molécula entonces
dibujamos por aquí la molécula tenemos
por aquí un grupo metilo por aquí
tenemos un hidrógeno el protón que
agregamos en el primer paso pero ahora
este enlace entre el carbono 3 y el
carbono 4 lo podemos pasar aquí entre el
carbono 2 y el carbono 3
entonces el enlace doble estaría por
aquí
esta es la otra estructura de resonancia
entonces le acabamos de quitar un enlace
a este carbono de aquí al carbono 4 este
carbono de aquí y entonces tiene una
carga positiva y es un kart vocación
pero sigue siendo un kart vocación al
ico y otra vez pensando en el mecanismo
este a nyon cloruro funciona como el
núcleo filo llega y le hace un ataque
núcleo público a este electro filo y
entonces dibujemos el producto por aquí
y ahora tenemos un doble enlace por aquí
entre el carbono 3 y el carbono 2
tenemos un grupo metilo en el carbono 2
y estamos agregando el cloro en el
carbono número 4 entonces por aquí
tenemos el cloro y si quisiéramos poner
el nombre iupac de esta molécula
empezaríamos a enumerar por aquí 1
456 y entonces esto sería 6 cloro 1
metil ciclo externo así es que estas dos
moléculas son exactamente iguales pero
de hecho este va a ser el producto
minoritario ok
minoritario el producto de menor
cantidad y la diferencia entre este
producto y los otros dos que vimos
arriba es que aquí este kart vocación
este kart vocación de aquí es un kart
boca tiene secundario que está enlazado
con dos carbonos carl vocación al lille
y ccoo secundario y si lo comparamos con
los otros dos productos que obtuvimos
por aquí tenemos este carbó catión al
índico
pero este car boca tiene lilly co es un
car vocacional y lico terciario gray
terciario y entonces es más estable que
un kart vocación a lírico secundario
entonces este va a ser el producto
mayoritario no yo y dario cree que estas
dos moléculas que ya vimos que son
distintas sean el producto mayor en
cantidad y la otra reacción que vimos
esta reacción este producto va a ser el
producto menor en cantidad fue un poco
de trabajo a encontrar todos los
productos pero observa el mecanismo y
piensa acerca de la adicción 12 en
contraste con la visión 14 y piensa en
la estabilidad del oscar vocaciones